i i think that you know we've all grown
up and even in historians and even on
you know on the gram and all of these
places you see the historic willis reed
coming back
right and playing in that game isaiah
forever foreign hurt he's limping
uh you know doing the game but the one
thing about that you know
isaiah got hurt during the middle of the
game but you know
walt frazier had 36 points and 19
assists that night that was the reason
yeah willis willis hit two quick buckets
it's a quick bucket that's it so
but what i i think in in the current
time
you have to prepare and when you're
preparing
for an opponent in a close-out game
and you think a guy is going to play
then everyone's preparation is different
and so now gasol oh you're going to
start tonight
oh drummond you're on the bench everyone
is different now
and for me i think the lack of uh
preparation
where i think i agree with chuck he
should have never even played
if you watch a guy in the first two
minutes both
chuck and i was like we're sitting there
like this what is he doing out there you
know
anybody you don't have to be a doctor to
see that he shouldn't be out yeah i i'm
i'm really pissed about that yeah
so the preparation was just you you
can't prepare and then kenny had upon it
so well he can't make it in the worst
yes you can yeah yes you can make it
worse you can make it worse
you've got something going on with your
legs you're gonna hurt another part of
your body but
they said the doctor cleared him to play
they need to they could need some better
doctors
62 to 41. that is your halftime score
it's game
six if the suns win they are into the
western conference semis
that's what it's like austin if you
would speed that up a little bit it'd be
a little more accurate